this video is sponsored by twin mirror
[Music]
what's up wisecrack helen here and today
we're talking about everyone's favorite
guilty pleasure true crime between all
the docu-series podcasts books and
reddit threads it seems that audiences
today can't get enough of real-life
stories about gruesome violence this
obsession has become so prevalent as to
even inspire satire and then there's
this bop
so there's clearly something compelling
about true crime and the way it lets us
consume content about grisly murder from
the comfort of our couches but what does
that say about us as human beings and as
a society are we all secret wannabe
serial killers nosy voyeurs or both or
does true crime serve some kind of real
emotional or psychological function
let's unravel the mystery in this
wisecrack edition while we can't stop
watching true crime
but before we get into it i want to talk
about this video sponsor twin mirror
twin mirror is an exciting game that's
finally made its way on the steam in it
you embody sam a journalist who has
returned to his west virginia hometown
after his old friend nick dies under
mysterious circumstances and the story
only gets more complex from there sam's
entire existence is complicated by the
presence of the devil a more sociable
version of himself that only he can see
who helps sam access feelings he
normally can't such as empathy sam with
help from the devil investigates his
friend nick's death by re-examining his
hometown and the people who live there
including nick's girlfriend and his
teenage daughter the game also lets you
access flashes from sam's memory helping
you piece together exactly how everybody
got where they are and how they can
possibly move forward it's a fascinating
often eerie game that gives you all the
thrills of solving a juicy mystery plus
it delves into topics that we here at
wisecrack really love like
self-perception moral relativity
societal pressures and more to get your
own copy of twin mirror and start
playing today click the link in the
video description and now back to the
show to understand the contemporary
obsession with true crime we have to
look back at the genre's historical
development now human beings have loved
stories about murder and punishing
murderers since biblical times but the
mass production of true crime media can
be traced back to one 15th century
invention the printing press apologies
to those of you who thought we were
about to mention the invention of the
spring coil at the time public execution
was still the preferred method of
punishment for capital crimes so
entrepreneurial printers started selling
broadsides or large posters at the
gallows which detailed those crimes this
gave spectators context for the
execution as they became extremely
popular these posters evolved into
folded pamphlets and started being
circulated far and wide publishers
caught on and began printing and
distributing an unprecedented amount of
true crime pamphlets across europe these
early pamphlets were especially popular
among clergy who presented them as
morality tales the stories often
included cd details about the
perpetrator's moral descent into violent
crime starting with such sins as
gambling going into debt and drinking
i'm only two out of three so i should be
good for now this degeneracy then
culminated in bloody murder the message
was straightforward stay on the narrow
path of salvation through jesus christ
or suffer the fate of one of these
miscreants the popularity of true crime
proved enduring in victorian england it
took the form of serialized penny
dreadfuls about detectives and criminals
in the american old west where
large-scale printing was harder to come
by criminals dastardly deeds were passed
down via murder ballads and with each
new advancement in mass media technology
came a new wave of true crime by the
time the 24-hour news networks hit the
scene audiences in the latter half of
the 20th century could be treated to
nightly tales of cold-blooded killings
today's media landscape of endless
podcasts and streaming services is no
different much of the true crime
produced today featured events that took
place some time ago and were covered
extensively by the news media at the
time this wealth of archival material
and an inexpensive production model have
made it easy to re-examine these past
cases and audiences are here for it so
why has our demand for retellings of
bloody murders sustained itself for so
many centuries why do the most heinous
crimes committed by mankind make good
fodder for casual entertainment well
neurology gives us one simple answer
witnessing cases of violence triggers
the release of adrenaline and when
you're in a controlled environment like
the comfort of your couch it can be very
stimulating it's basically triggering
the same reaction we have to watching
horror movies in extreme sports
psychologists have also theorized that
the obsession with true crime especially
among women can act as a survival
instinct watching how other women fell
victim to predators may actually ease
anxieties of this happening to the
viewer subconsciously they feel their
garnering insight into how they might
survive a similar attack even if that's
not necessarily the case but beyond the
individual reasons to watch true crime
there's also a social aspect to this
obsession it's why podcasts like cereal
and series like the jinx and making a
murderer became cultural touchstones
that you couldn't avoid talking about
and it's why the highly active fanbase
of the podcast my favorite murder
lovingly referred to themselves as
murderinos a good true crime show can
inspire the same water cooler
conversation once reserved for fans of
lost that's even a fan's only knowledge
of the crime comes from the media itself
this tendency to want to put crimes into
a narrative structure speaks to how we
as a society deal with events that are
so tragic they threaten our view of the
world true crime author and analyst
rebecca frost explains that in
responding to situations that have
disrupted communal order the crime
narrative functions as a restoration
ritual that aids members of the
community responding to and recovering
from the presented threat but rather
than simply reflecting the crime itself
these narratives also tell us a lot
about the societies that created them
much like how the overly religious
morality tales of early true crime
pamphlets reflected the values of the
late middle ages today's crime
narratives reflect our own values and
beliefs in sculpting the archetype of
the cold-blooded killer for example the
common contemporary narrative tends to
focus on universally recognized modern
psychology concepts like childhood
trauma in this way a supposedly
objective retelling of factual events
can inadvertently reinforce our own
biases literary professor mark selter
writes true crime is crime fact that
looks like crime fiction it marks or
irritates the distinction between real
and fictional reality basically true
crime is all the sludge between what
really happened which we can't access
and what maybe happened which we can
speculate about until reddit stops
upvoting us and the way these narratives
have shifted over time could tell us a
lot about how society has changed
especially in regards to crime and
punishment and to understand that we
need to come back to french philosopher
and wisecrack icon michel foucault in
his 1975 book discipline and punish
foucault compared and contrasted the
archaic practice of public execution
with our modern system of police and
prisons he questioned her current
practice of institutionalizing criminals
and executing the most heinous ones
behind closed doors and he asked whether
it's any more humane than the good old
days of drawing and quartering criminals
for the whole town to see importantly he
examined how both of these practices are
more about maintaining power than
deterring crime he argued that ending
the practice of public execution was
less about treating criminals more
humanely and more about hiding the
cruelty of the justice system itself he
wrote about the way public executions
accustomed spectators to cruelty in
order to scare them away from committing
crimes at the same time public
executions turned executioners and
judges into literal murderers which was
also really scary but here's the problem
it also made people kind of empathize
with the brutally tortured criminals big
no-no were the true crime pamphlets of
the past often reveled in the details of
violent punishment today's true crime
rarely goes beyond the conviction of the
crime itself instead it focuses on the
investigation and occasionally the trial
and sentencing but there's a problem
inherent in this practice see the main
source of information about these
processes is inevitably the police and
the prosecutors and this gets ethically
messy because those parties have a
vested interest in shaping the
narratives around crime see the public
is rarely exposed to the brutally
punitive measures of the criminal
justice system and it's also fed a
steady diet of the grisly details of the
crimes themselves this leads to a
heavily skewed perspective it's no
wonder that multiple studies have shown
that consuming large amounts of crime
related media is correlated with
political support for more crime control
and punitive measures focusing on the
investigation also legitimizes the
methods used by the authorities forensic
sciences are used by police to
investigate crimes by prosecutors to
establish guilt in the courtroom and by
forensics experts testifying in court
and they're generally accepted by the
judicial system and society as a whole
despite the fact that these techniques
are rarely subjected to the same
experimental rigor as other purely
scientific theories ballistics
fingerprinting and even aspects of dna
analysis have all come into question by
the scientific community and yet they're
still used to put people behind bars
it's entirely possible we'll scoff at at
least some of these methods someday the
same way we now know better than to rely
on blood spatter or fly detectors the
role of the media in legitimizing these
practices to the public has been a topic
of debate among criminologists for
decades a 2004 usa today article coined
the term the csi effect to describe the
tendency of juries to demand ever more
forensic evidence from trial prosecutors
foucault addresses this as well again
contrasting these techniques with the
medieval methods of establishing guilt
which usually consisted of um simply
torturing the suspect until they
confessed these confessions were widely
accepted at the time as clear evidence
of guilt after all why would someone
confess to a crime they didn't commit
it's now pretty well known that
confessions made under duress are not
reliable that said across the board
confessions made under a variety of
sometimes suspect circumstances are
still taken seriously under law to much
harm according to the innocence project
29 of recent dna exonerations were cases
where defendants confessed to murders
they hadn't committed and the same
skepticism perhaps should be applied to
our current methods of forensic
investigation foucault argued that the
expansion of the criminal investigation
is less about establishing truth and
more about reinforcing the power of the
institutions which control the
investigation he explains that among its
many functions forensic science grants
the judicial system an illusory sense of
scientific authority that is then
treated as objective truth it's also
self-perpetuating in granting itself its
own legitimacy as we've said the
institution of the church back in the
middle ages used true crime to reinforce
its own necessity to society similarly
today's true crime may be working
intentionally or otherwise to reinforce
institutions like the police the courts
and the prison system as a whole
now to its credit the most recent wave
of true crime seems to be taking an
active role in examining the justice
system itself hbo's the jinx detail just
how much criminals can get away with if
they have money and social status and
netflix's making a murderer showed us
just how easy it is for law enforcement
to manipulate forensic evidence and
coerce confessions and the popularity of
these shows has had real life
consequences the jinx's robert durst was
finally convicted of the murder of susan
berman
of course and when for example serials
and non-syed and making a murderer's
brendan dassey appeal their convictions
it makes the news this new wave of true
crime has also spurred the creation of
communities of internet sleuths who
conduct independent research and
exchange their results this can
sometimes lead to positive outcomes the
late michelle mcnamara spent years
researching and compiling information on
the serial rapist and murderer who would
become known as the golden state killer
she along with prominent internet crime
daddy paul holes can be credited with
eventually tracking down the murderer of
course there's a dark side to this trend
as well netflix's recent cecil hotel
docu-series highlighted how internet
sleuthing can easily snowball into
fantastical conspiracy theories this can
have devastating effects on innocent
people who are mistaken for suspects
they're saying i'm a suspect for
for murder
more they're all felicia
not to mention re-traumatizing victims
of crimes and their families aside from
the ethics of true crime and internet
sleuthing we don't think it's a
coincidence that these two phenomena
emerge simultaneously as we explained
mass media has both created and met the
demand for true crime all along that
continues today netflix's true
crime-related offerings alone grew 63
between 2018 and 2021 for example but
that's hardly the only effect of mass
media it also tends to democratize
knowledge which often leads to periods
of great social upheaval take our old
friend the printing press this new
technology didn't just create a boom in
true crime it's also credited with
spurring the protestant reformation
which challenged the authority of the
catholic church see expanded literacy
rates along with the widespread
distribution of religious literature led
to a mass decentralization of religious
knowledge without the need for a papal
authority to interpret the scripture
differing religious denominations began
to pop up all over europe this often led
to heated and sometimes violent clashes
between these different sects it also
instigated major crackdowns on dissent
from religious authorities it's no
coincidence that during this time of
social upheaval people found escape in
the allure of true crime along with
easing their anxieties about the
violence happening around them it likely
helped to reinforce their beliefs in
justice and order and our current time
is no different the internet has created
a mass awareness about all kinds of
injustices and abuses of authority and
inspired a number of mass social
movements during these uncertain times
true crime can be soothing for society
watching individual injustices get
properly investigated and even resolved
is satisfying an even true crime that
highlights very real miscarriages of
justice can make amateur sleuths feel
that they're part of correcting those
injustices which is also satisfying at a
time when the world feels completely
unpredictable there is a certain comfort
in the illusion of control that true
crime presents us with but at the same
time we gotta wonder is the
entertainment we're consuming weirdly
reinforcing the very systems of
injustice we're mad at and are our
guilty pleasures creating a demand for
content that can only be met by
exploiting tragedies and re-traumatizing
victims what do you guys think is
binging boatloads of content about
real-life violence a-okay for our brains
in our society or are we just exploiting
tragedies for our own entertainment and
peace of mind tell us what you think in
the comments big thanks to our patrons
for all your support and check out our
podcast smash that subscribe button with
blunt force and don't forget to ring
that bell and as always thanks for
watching
peace
[Music]
you